uh on this move we're we're doing chino
henko
in a different way so not the
12 6 x y okay
uh aikido's footwork doesn't doesn't
make sense from 12
6 x y okay um
or the single opponent but when the
fight starts rotating
10 con you ten edb tank on a lot
okay so uh the first thing we're doing
here
is i'm going to bring him into a
different angle
i'm taking away the 12-6 so i'm not here
he comes in and i bring
i already started that rotation you see
and then i can do the edd
so a yin
absorption
but i do have to eat me
don't just don't go here he's past
me and then
[Music]
get in that back arm
start the fight
okay okay i just want to focus on
footwork today but
the footwork has a timing not just a
spatial
aspect so
the grip is going to be my
measuring tool so when i tencon
at the wrong rate or the wrong degree of
rotation
uh this you will start to pull the
fingers
so i'm going to put my anime here i do
my rotation and you can see i'm going to
pull on his fingers
this way and it leaves an outward
pulling energy
for him what i want to do with the grip
is always be pushing
my forearm into his palm
here like that
not same grip not taking his fingers
and pulling them pulling them
pushing his palm the entire arm
into the technique i'll show you the
difference here's a pull
full
i'm on the other side i'm on the other
side
i step to stay on the other side rotate
to stay on the other side
and it's always pushing him
and now it's always just pushing
the pull
and push
[Music]
so using the hand as the metric you can
see
if i step here i
am too far back i'm not in this
part okay
so on this side i go here i'm going to
step here that's going to be a pull
can you see that because i am on the
inside of the circle that i'm about to
draw
okay it's going to be a pull you see
okay well
i'm not in the back i'm not on the
positive side of the circle
so what happens let's say that
he got deflected at this way or i
deviated
and when he turns to fight and i do my
turn
here i'm actually not able to keep ahead
of him on the spiral
so he keeps turning i
[Music]
he keeps turning i keep turning and i
can stay in the back of that
corner
so you're using the hand
but you need to pay attention that
you're here
do you think that you're there
and i go to there
my goal is to get on the positive side
of his aggressive
recalibrating towards me once i start
the fight rotating he's got to rotate
inside that
to get a line attached back on me and i
need to be in that
corner so that i can stay ahead of that
i go right here now every time he turns
into me
he's gonna be behind me okay
boom in
this is uh count three right this
single pivot point is what allows me to
do that
so if i go here and i double pivot point
we're gonna we're gonna stop the fight
i do have i'm on the other side of the
circle but i'm gonna double pivot point
rotation he's going to turn at me and
i'm turning at him
and you see i'm not ahead of the circle
so i'm doing on the other side so i go
oh i said i'm gonna head in a circle
but now i'm gonna double pivot point
he's gonna double through the point and
i'm not
ahead of the circle
so really pay attention when you enter
here
you'll weight shifts onto that you can
see i'm continuing to move
to the young side of the circle so as he
rotates
you have a deviation in the weight shift
warm in
okay don't start rotating here keep
shifting into the young position of that
foot
until now you've completed that yang
cycle
there's nowhere left to go and that's
where the yin cycle is born
i'm going to take off the hand now okay
and he's going to rotate and i'm going
to rotate
and i can't rotate anymore and that's
when i take the other foot
in
you have a second rule to do you're
going to try to dress
and i keep turning
boom
and you can see that it is still a push
you see i'm still pushing so i don't
need to be on the inside and grab him
i'm still pushing
in turn you see he's still pushing down
on the inside
pushing pushing pushing
so don't forget to roll okay don't go to
sleep here
he's trying to turn okay so
he turns and i start the second
deviation with the weight shift
then step into the in space
boom boom
this turn you're not walking around
anymore you're trying to
address on me here there he goes
[Music]
he's here deviate
okay let's try okay
let's pre-summarize so the hand
the grip is used as a metric to tell me
if i'm in the right place
on the shoulder how well if i'm pulling
on the hand i will not be in the right
place for the shoulder
okay which is why once once i understand
where i'm supposed to be
you can start changing it and you're
still okay
so if i was out here and i pull and he
turns on me i'm not going to be
okay
[Music]
and we're doing this because the
original xy is kind of misleading and
the beginner's always thinking x y you
picture this guy over there and you're
going to try to get there
no i'll we'll get there in the end and
i'll explain to you how this might work
okay as i said when when things really
start happening that's when aikido
footwork makes sense
xy things are not happening okay
so we are going to artificially create a
different angle you could have done it
like this
the guy does comes in over here do you
see
he comes in over here and i do the same
flip work
you could have done that but i wanted to
combine another skill
which is this skill how do i take
the original uh axis of rotation
from the x y axis and just by shifting
my weight i've changed it
i've changed it that's a very important
skill so we're combining two skills
as i do this if i'm doing everything
correct so i'm not here we're in the
second drill
and i single pivot point he um
i had him try and turn into me and i was
using that to measure okay
but he's not uh
going around me on his own
okay so i'm here and i'm just you you
don't move
you don't he's trying not to move
going to move why is he going to move
now
am i doing this no i'm pushing
so every time i stress his line of
gravity he has to move to adjust it do
you see that
it's not it's not him sticking to my
hand
and then him doing the adhesion
and it's not him walking around me okay
and the reason why that's a problem
is i don't have to do any of this right
if he's going to position himself
so you go ahead and do that you see i
could be i'm way to f
out here if i got in the right spot
and i'm here on on uh where i'm supposed
to be
this is pushing do you see it's pushing
then and then i can use the ik adhesion
so i push
i want him to go this way here he is
it's not him so he and again the greater
he does the more
he he does not want to go it creates you
see
it creates the adhesion it makes it
easier to do
it's the guy who's just standing there
oh that that one is a lot harder to do
but the guy who doesn't want to go
oh he's gonna go he's gonna go in a
circle
okay so don't get confused trying to
try to when you're
[Music]
i don't want you doing that dressage
pony trick and you're like sticking here
that's not helping anyone
okay so i'm here boom i'm moving him
we could do this same drill like that
i'm moving here
with the push out
this center is going like that
moving his line of gravity out here but
at this point
okay let's play with that a little bit
so that the uk is stocked up
okay let's go right okay
so i'm using my hand metrics we'll go
back to the previous drill
so he's he's uh now turning into me to
address
okay and let's give him like a just a
block okay do you get it
so he goes here and he's going to block
boom just give me another
line of attack he's going to lose the
first line of attack and comes in both
there you go
and i'll clear the hand so he's not
freaked out
okay
[Music]
okay let's let's get luke
okay so we just gave him
a new linear vector and that can
represent
anything kick knee clinch
tackle double leg takedown doesn't
doesn't matter
we're just working on the strategy
of idiom 10 okay so you can see
if i can't go in that would be a clash
i can't go straight back that's not
gonna do me anything
so we do the single point pivot he goes
and i'm on the other side
so he's gonna go uh as he's gonna be as
athletic as he can
okay so one boom
there you go
so the single point pivot
again i'm not going like this he goes
i'm not going like that you see he'll
clip
you if your line of gravity is in the
middle of your feet you're double
pivoting
you're staying on the line of attack
longer than you think you are
that's what we went in over in the third
count of the eight council buddy
so instead we're here
[Music]
time your turn
okay let's try so
when when i push i don't do a bracing
angle
so my my center can ground vector
on on the fly i don't need to get this a
frame here i can just walk
my job was to do a spinal displacement i
have to do that that's prescribed as
a bouquet antenna so i am doing that
but i'm not doing it from here
my body has to displace his spine his
spinal displacement
means his spine is there and i displace
it with my spine
not spinal manipulation i'm not doing
that when he does the first yin
absorption if i do a bracing angle
you're going to have your line of
gravity fall out of your base of support
and you kind of stumble and then you're
going to turn but you already have this
gap
if had this happened he should have just
knocked me
the reason i'm deviating is i don't have
the
my for a strike
but this is a very unrealistic thing i
can't really do anything with this
in a training environment so
he does the first deviation with the arm
clear
and i'm here i'm in perfect balance he
didn't do
anything to affect my base of support
right
my movement is here
just like if he bombs under the right
cross
i don't go
i turn and face the guy
so it's the same thing abstractly done
my body moves in with me and i turn
if i go flying by him
then he can double pivot and do all that
crazy
my movement is much tighter
body is moving by you
even when it doesn't change with the
block
when i take that line i distract him
body move
so he's gonna do the foot maneuvers
and he has to do it right
okay he brings his face of support back
in with his balance
i'm over here watch watch as he starts
to turn
i'm rotating with him
not i get out of the way
he's constantly going around
[Music]
you have to have that timing one is here
he turns i'm turning with him
[Music]
do that side again
not here and i'm deviating
we're here he's rotating i'm rotating
deviation
[Music]
rotating rotating
rotate
deviation
okay pay attention keep up the pace okay
so uh we're gonna come into keyhole in a
little bit
so he starts to turn right long on the
other side
i'm on the other side here
so uh sometimes again abstractly
a smart attacker realizes i'm going to
give my back
and they'll push through the vortex
you're trying to create
it's kind of happening here just in the
drug okay
and i want to address that until and
before we go someplace else
so he's turning in on me and he realizes
he missed and he pulls out of
that vortex
it feels like the worst strategy is
actually the sounder of the two
okay so we're gonna deal with that one
first so
i'm here and because i'm moving here
you're gonna find that you can get that
if i'm doing the deviation you're not
going to get it
and that is part of your footwork
is to reconcile offense and defense
you your your defense should be your
offense your offense should be your
defense and it
was not happening at the cost of the
other so you don't
you don't want to deviate at the cost of
i can't do anything
you have to constantly threaten your
office has to constantly
be there so he goes
and uk was doing what because just
running through
right that's what you guys were doing
okay
what do you think that is gonna do stop
not run through you are gonna run
through
okay so once he goes
[Music]
oh
so
okay so the purpose of this
technique is to measure
whether i am in the right place so at
the beginning
our metrics were the grip are you
pushing or pulling
the second one was uh
are you behind the corner of this
shoulder
are you single point pivoting or double
point pivoting
then we gave some reason to
why you want to double point pivot but
what happened is
everyone starts to milk the drill so we
had to do a
caveat don't do a bracing angle
spinal displacement that is not the
prescribed attack
there's nothing affecting your base of
support so you should be pushing with
your base of support
then you can get a new line of attack on
the guy which we
abstractly just gave a linear vector to
but then what's what'd we see oh okay
the guy did that and i'm just moving out
of the way
again you are taking more mat space
you're taking more time he has to be
less athletic than
you for that to work what i'm doing
instead
is i'm i'm here i'm in the back
do you see i'm hiding out here
whoa this hand's already there
he goes
if i'm double pivoting i'm doing all
this wrong
this has way out of range
if i was hiding out in the corner this
time is also
close
[Music]
and your yin absorption is in the elbow
as
it always is so young
it's not a clash i'm not sitting here he
goes and i go boom that's not what i'm
doing
i'm letting him through
right here living it through
[Music]
oh
come on okay so let's go back
i'm going to do all of this wrong so i'm
gonna i'm gonna be here
i'm on the inside of the circle so i'm
pulling
which means i'm not behind where i'm
supposed to be
i'm double pivoting okay
he now i have when we
if he starts to address i have to do an
external deviation
i'm not in the shikaku
not in the back okay which means i have
to now fight
again to reconcile the xy
conflict so he comes in and i have to do
it again
every time i'm required to do something
again
i'm in the 50 50.
i could the second time i might not make
it
so you don't want to train to do it
again and i want these skills and i want
to understand it even ten times
so again this is all just kihon
abstraction
okay so let's say i'm over here
and as i said the new metric was this uh
cookie nugget and i can't do it when i'm
doing all those things wrong
and i'm over here so what do you have to
do
you got to get the kazushi again
[Music]
that's why you want to go into idi
or the other coke united is you you
don't you're out of place
to do the technique you're out of place
in place well maybe you get there maybe
you don't
but every time you roll the dice
it's not that you all now i get a second
chance again you get a second chance of
not getting it
okay so this technique is here
i'm already in place when he turned and
i turned like this
the kazushi is already in place so
there's no need to set it up again
that's what we want i'm in here it's
already in place
so
okay come on okay the second
response that the guy can do which is
more
common but not as skilled is he
turning he realizes he's not there
you're not there
and he's going to make a second
adjustment
and this is where the spiral geometry
starts
okay so i'm here
he makes it realizes i'm not there and
he turns in again
okay
[Music]
okay he turn turn it one more time
and he's gonna allow me on the tank on
to
do the projection
long turning turn returning
i don't i'm not reaching for him
around here going like this you see i'm
on the line
the technique is happening he's turning
he takes one more tight turn and there's
so we're going to keep the abstract
you'll still find that the technique
here
i don't care what you grab you grab the
head you grab the ribs you can grab the
cape it doesn't matter okay but you
can't
you got to go back to your original
itself
okay so you're turning and trying to
keep turning on the guy
he's not there keep turning on the guy
okay
okay okay to understand the strategy
behind the footwork
we're using abstract vectors okay um
and then the problem is that you want to
go back in technique
so this guy comes here and then you go
like
and then if we give them like a double
leg takedown or a
jab cross you're lost you don't know
what to do
okay so the metric i'm going to use here
is he rotates he's he's here like that
i don't i don't want to pick techniques
if i don't have to
i don't want pink hands ever okay but as
you're trying to understand this uh
as he goes i don't want to go like
his aggression in his aggression in my
response to his aggression
the kazushi is is present so as he goes
you can just hold pull down a corner
he goes park and you can have it
you don't you don't have to touch
anything so i what i would do is
whatever you're touching that's what you
use
okay so i'm here he goes home there's
his hand
and i project on his arm
you can even uh you know he's really
aggressive
you can just stop and the guy will go
past you
do you get it
but we're here it won't pop
so what do i look for how do i know the
difference of that your mind is
different
when you do the techniques your mind's
out here you see you're trying to stop
the thing from happening and gain
control
i'm not doing that he countered my
counter
do you see and so the ten con is setting
up
the movement here
how taking that line of gravity
back that way so he goes
and you can see i'm much closer than the
other technique
and then add your cocky projection
that's different to me than this
okay okay so uh
when we come here go slower the fight
starts to rotate because of what i did
okay and his aggression
okay so it starts to rotate
i oh he took a second turn do you see
that
he took the second turn so it's his
aggression
i'm going to do one more step so look at
it this way i'm on the back
rotating on the back do you see that
when he does the second turn
i have to rotate on the front so i'm on
the back
i'm going to control your pace okay on
the back and you run it on the front and
i'll rotate on the front
do you see that so
back back rotation back to chest
rotation
boom he turned inside my circle i rotate
chest to chest rotation
you see that okay that's the db10 front
on a single pivot point so double pivot
point
you're going to see they're not the same
i'm going to take my step there's no
rotation
here single pivot rotate
rotate rotate rotate he turned inside of
it rotate body
this way so his
aggression
boom boom chest chest rotation
my my deviation creates the void
you see it's not that i
pull him even even when i'm here
he goes he's falling into it
you see and
even when i supplement that with the
angle cancellation on the hand
i'm not pulling him there's an adhesion
it's going out
[Music]
the the centrifugal energy
assist me going out we'll add the
adhesion and his aggression
creates the spiral not me
rotate rotate rotate too fast
rotate rotate rotate now chest chest
rotates that's where the step comes in
you see come back
rotate rotate rotate chest comes in
that's where the tempo is there i keep
him going out
his aggression just turning in and now
he has some weight going that way
and that's what i add to the coq
projection
and pop out he goes okay
all of your techniques are here so
here rotate rotate rotate there
is your titan argument
boom he goes warm
your cookie nuggets
[Music]
freaking is he takes another turn that's
your pushy nuggets
inside you take a tighter turn inside
okay got it all right try it
so my aggression it's not me
running around
out here that's not what ikea's footwork
is about
it's for truly aggressive people so
i bring i am doing that as part of the
prescription of kihon
but my there's nothing affecting my base
so my base is here
now nobody would do this
again i throw the right cross he's over
my rotation is right there
so same thing he goes
boom i'm here here
now i'm going to do another turn inside
because he deviated please
there he goes like that i'm not going to
walk around
and come back from that angle
here here so it looks like
one move on my part
you see now you can start to see the
centrifugal energy on my body
wait okay
that's what luke is doing okay okay i'm
going to call that the
strategic architecture
it's a particular
combination of geometric patterns
okay but it is not the modes of
operation so the modes of operation
are always eye key and cue okay it's
true you're creating void external voids
and the guy
uh falls in it he kind of loses his
balance but i'm not dependent upon those
all right when you become dependent upon
those i'm going to be faster than the
guy
um and then i still have to project them
so i got to be able to accelerate them
so i got to be stronger too
and then he has to be less athletic he
can't get his face to support
under that line so we're still we're
over here what i mean by that
i come like this and then i'm like doing
this stuff
uh that's those are the wrong modes of
operation
so as we go and we come like this
this hand is not not doing anything
this sound is adhering right he
he's it's adhering with the centripetal
centripetal energy
so we're doing this you see and i'm
going to create an ik adhesion here
it doesn't take any muscle
and as i create the ik adhesion here
right or here this hand
just ground vectors well here we are
we're in this position
here goes ike adhesion and boom
so there's no wrestling of my arms
boom
my arms stay relaxed okay
again i think as this is different
i'm in the right spot but this is
different too
okay